et
[Musique]
la cosmo lune et le cos moto bus sont
quelque part dans l'espace
l'egypte vit pour échapper à la maladie
de la terre sont parties in extremis en
laissant le gibier ou à la garde de
légère il faut dire qu'on devenant vieux
les jbe était devenu un peu méchant et
c'était sans aucun regret kind et c'est
là l'un des leurs ah il est loin le
temps où l'on vous disait l'égibilité de
petits animaux très gentil avec un petit
chapeau sur la tête pour pouvoir se dire
bonjour il était très très intelligent
intelligent il était toujours mais du
côté de la gentillesse
alors là vraiment il était grand temps
qu'ils retournent chez eux se refaire
une santé
les jbe partie la terre calme et sereine
au devin la planète gêne qu'elle avait
toujours été gégène tous les matins on
est le jpy fourrage et j'aime ce beach
ça me voyais aller si vous vouler savoir
on part de la place gégène qui est bien
déserte maintenant on suit l'avenue
gégène tout du long jusqu'aux faubourgs
gêne un peu plus loin vous verrez on
bute sur une rivière
on la traverse au dg jeunes n'arrivent
et on la longe le temps d'une cigarette
ou deux quand on arrive au carrefour
gégène au lieu de tourner à gauche on
pour le raccourci par les dunes à
travers les oyats et l'église net et on
tombe sur la plage gégène devenu depuis
gégène pêche quand vous irez vous
reconnaitre djiby s'amuse est un peu sur
la plage construisait des châteaux il
faisait des pâtés mais on voit les biens
confond il s'ennuie et quelquefois quand
les ter et teoz sur l'eau le soir quand
la fraîche tombée on pouvait voir les
sous-marins shadoks faire surface pour
danser le charleston et faire du ski
noté
[Musique]
il jouait et perdait des fortunes
colossales d'or et de diamants de mer
qui ne valaient rien dans des casinos
qui n'existait pas encore et les jours
passent et facile et selon nous un jour
du gy be dit je vais aller à la pêche
aux crevettes
tu sais lui dit gentil mot gégène c'est
un peu tôt dans la saison des crevettes
il n'y en a pas encore sur la terre
[Musique]
mais ce soir-là de gy be fou ne revint
pas de la pêche aux crevettes
[Musique]